they're warning
this is gonna be weirder than usual
can't be helped
you called me so here i am
i know i shut you out sometimes
i'm always glad to hear from you
it's just that i get my hopes up
so many times it's led to nothing
i found nothing
it's like we live in a room
and there's a poster on the wall
we stare at it and we think that's the
whole world
the room and the poster
the picture's something nice a landscape
a famous person
like in that movie what is it called
the prison movie the room's a cell
and the picture it's different for each
of us it can be beautiful
or terrible but we're all transfixed
but it's all a lie something to distract
us from the truth
they're lying to us we're lying
to ourselves the rooms not the world
the world is much bigger
and much stranger
there's a hole hidden behind that poster
that leads to the real world
we all feel safe in that room
but sometimes sometimes something crawls
out from behind the poster
and the ones that see it happen freak
out
and try to forget what they saw
i'm here
why did you bring me here
hello anyone here
yeah i see it but what is it
i can feel it it resonates
the things you show me my friend i
forgot that
it's all on my head there's you
right
i need someone to point me in the right
direction
this seal i saw it a long
time ago i keep seeing it in my dreams
federal bureau of control
all these years i've been looking for
them and they were hiding in plain sight
hello
[Music]
hey excuse me
there you are you are here about the job
janitor's assistant you need to go to
the
interview go that way to the elevator
thanks elevator that way
got it very good i'm actually
a janitor by the way you'll work for me
you can say i sent you
if they don't hire you either you are no
hell of it
there'll be work for the axe take them
behind the sound
done enough night shift lunar jobs to
know it makes us come off weird
auntie the janitor is a friendly face in
my book
better than somebody with no face at all
think about it no face
but that said i know what you're
thinking
if there's an ax murderer around that's
him
the cell and the poster
i was 11 years old the first time i saw
behind the poster
they told me i imagined it
i've been trying to pull it down ever
since
will you help
did i lose you there for a moment you
know what's on my mind
my baby brother dylan 17
years since the men of this bureau took
him
so
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
you want me to pick it up the murder
weapon really
and there goes the poster objects of
power
can cause or be results of awes altered
world events intrusions upon the
perceived reality
now the service weapon is of course
a prime example of an oop a very
powerful one ingrained in the bureau's
dna a key
component in our prime candidate program
come out of that russian roulette a
winner and you
you're it
[Music]
look at this where am i
sorry
huh the same gun
okay now i have a gun
foreign
[Music]
something's coming
this threat an attack
duty as director
keep the bureau safe
did you hear that
it's the dead man right after the
pyramid spoke to me and it was just
noise and
i understood every word
and this gun's alive you know what
i'm happy happy to be here
things have quieted down outside is it
safe to
so go can't let this happen you can't
let this out
you can't let this happen you can't let
this happen
you can't let this happen
you can't let this happen
you stopped it you
oh thank you that was
horror
the hotline secure line of communication
guidelines
uh
myself
foreign
here
reminder if you experience an
unanticipated shift
follow these simple steps search the
room
the hissing sound that tried to invade
me earlier
the hiss burrowing into everything
in this place is the hiss your enemy
all right it's our enemy
that babbles contagious it burrows in
like an infuriating melody that makes
you hum it over and
over
hmm
must cleanse control points
an enemy
what does that mean help me fix it
holy [ __ ] you did it
we did it hello
are you with us we're the bureau
are you still insane
please talk to me we saw you
deal with the compromised agents
is it safe to come out
leave your insights
fight
so
reminder if you experience an
unanticipated building
believe yourself
the fingers
happy enough
foreign
so
i can't tell you how happy i am to talk
to somebody saying
the feeling's mutual yeah i'm pope emily
pope
and dr darling's assistant my turn
should i lie jesse faden
i'm just visiting i should have lied oh
[ __ ] you're the new director
hold on we're coming out
director faden call me jesse
okay jessie i'm emily
look somehow this hostile force this
hiss that works somehow the hiss managed
to infiltrate the building without any
warning and just like that
my name for it is official the hiss
like the sound of poison gas leaking in
we're in full lockdown it seems to have
spread everywhere
and to everyone not protected by an hra
and extraordinarily you
you are the director and that makes you
special by definition
trench is no longer the director
obviously
i'm sorry i'm talking too much this
whole situation is just
a lot trench is dead
shot ah i found
his body and the gun
do i tell her it looked like a suicide
the service weapon
also and this can sound crazy
he keeps appearing to me saying things
it's hard to make out but he told me to
cleanse the control point
push the hiss out the whole room shifted
around
you did that and you entered the
building when it was already in the
lockdown
before you became the new director how
i'm not ready to tell her about you yet
a janitor let me in
i love it this is [ __ ] unbelievable
it's i can't even
look jesse i have a million questions
and you probably have a million more
like do you know my brother dylan
not yet but there's something
i need to ask you to do first if you can
cleanse a control point then you can
maybe cure
those infected or possessed by the hiss
because if that's possible our options
are very different
emily pope i don't know her
but i like her already she's the
opposite of the faceless agency i've
blamed for what happened to me for so
long
but i can't trust her yet or rather the
bureau
she's a part of yes
i can try i'm speaking for you of course
we can try it together
okay you with me we did it before
push the hiss out
ugh
it didn't work the hiss has burrowed too
deep
i can't cleanse them i saw
it was worth a shot thank you director
jesse
i'm gonna tell her why i'm here i'll
risk it
listen the bureau was involved in an
incident in my hometown ordinary
17 years ago the bureau came in and
covered the whole thing up
i've been looking for this place for a
long time
that's enough maybe that's too much
already
i can't tell her about dylan and the
rest yet
i've seen mentions of an altered world
event case dealing with ordinary
you were at ground zero as a child
it was one of the big ones and before my
time
and very classified i can try to dig out
some old files for you
my boss casper darling would know but
he's missing i think he knew this was
coming or
suspected he came up with the hras the
hedren resonance amplifiers
i think they're what saved us a few of
us
and director trench would know trench
the ghost or whatever he is
he mentioned something called the
hotline
said i should find it it's another
object of power like the gun
an old bakelite telephone a direct
line of communication between the
director and the board
maybe he can talk to you more clearly
through that
trench has years and years of experience
he might know how to destroy the hiss
where is the hotline it's kept in the
communications department through the
mail room
it's part of this sector so we can
access it even with the lockdown in
place
we'll get the door open for you okay
that's my next stop that's tamazi's
department
he's the head of communications i don't
think he had an hra he
kind of made a point about not wearing
one earlier keep an eye out
they call me the director but that's not
me
i'm not a director type not a leader
why am i here i think you already know
yes i came for my brother but there are
other reasons too
i said i was looking for answers but i
might never
understand them i'm not
looking for proof this is already it
more than enough
no matter what they told me all those
years i know
it's real now i didn't imagine this
i want to be a part of this world
what scares me shitless is that i
finally found it
only to see the hiss destroy it all
i know this is all new to you so